okay commie bastards it's a it's a bus a
cup apple so we're going to do I think
chapter [ __ ] two eight or so I would
I think it's safe I don't really talk
and no no penny likes me on it's like
it's all blur like Saturday and even all
[ __ ] day notice I just know when the
taxman comes to get taxes you better
[ __ ] Pam or us I'll take care of kids
okay there you go that's optimism it's
so fun I don't have to walk because this
guy is pushing me I'm not walking right
now
hey get going scum let's let me team
here
oh sure community becomes what yeah sure
yeah it's deploy wrangle me up great was
the [ __ ] dentist's office
hello sir ah what is that
sure
my Catalan has placed now to stay car
they put it as a masterful relevant set
Rock count for [ __ ] in here yeah
get up yeah he's been a bad boy hey guys
let's go over there it sucks to me yo
[ __ ] the audience the first day is tough
me explain clear to accept but it's no
easier ah now I can Ravana how many
weeks long and wonderful I never thought
Minister bike for long I was sweating
enough even F the guy Hilton better
allowed might in the look he was too
strong now I just tried to survive I'm
looking for a man said frog Maya
personally survived in here longer than
any other even got for J want to program
Timmy director uniforms look for
prisoner over there
bangarang in a block for uniform sanam
is Milo I heard his wife's it's caught
it in our block maybe that will convince
them to change uniforms with your but do
you need to distract the guard first
every awful what does that say
I'll press the button this is a way to
distract the guy what she what am I
going to do
I'm pressing a perfect yeah la that's
outside sorry I am doing here okay
let me keep the one [ __ ] bro
I hate that show is your horse ready
here goes
how do I get that how do I get that [ __ ]
now I'm tired of working hey don't make
me work anymore now
Holly shut sir I don't why they keep
your wife good yeah Molly Pagadian the
same well I gotta go to this if you were
that one uniforms you can find out for
yourself
they are brother which is perfect
mummy-ji Java moving on fine Dallara
think is more tree blocking of our
mechanical a cornice one meter there
mama Lou so Matilda your uncle myself on
this I've connected by a bank you start
exhausting get the [ __ ] I cut the
other side aunt I suppose our fears of
does all the door ain't I smoked eggs
does the follow-up I hope you sign with
JC clay sale I mean is going back over
but they're like yours maybe connect I
like the letter I got here wait is there
[ __ ] in here now they're not going to
[ __ ] it executes leave it take so long
the [ __ ] sir
look at you
buchenwald from east to west
some call me hey Babette I saw you they
will mean you shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
crazy Conya hello sir
sad-looking people in here is a [ __ ]
anything I could eat in here and I
shower tired around here you have you
seen my brother
[ __ ] get this gyptian so much muscle a
physique you up [ __ ] over
you said Roth I'm not sure yet what do
you know I've said lot if not you should
source of the Nazi technology I'm here
to rescue you you're here to lift this
is wonderful he's here police give me
little rescue him and then our day of
action don't waste your time I swore an
oath to never be played a secret to pass
you [ __ ] your own be more doctor all
America resistance calls on you so with
the production of thought right my
personal freedom for the secrets I swore
to keep place my honor on the oval of
righteousness well they'll leave in a
moment to consider our Shenzhen
my proposition we might um not aid me in
closing this place down and I will teach
you and you'll come when people eat ruin
our deal I've been working on over the
logic that machine the folks because of
stolen does use technology I know it
very well
now this don't look at the so bluntly
this for this I can seize control over
that machine level the gates of this
place free everyone I only miss one more
path by MIT and the power salon now at
the machine well if electrical systems
are powered by be born again
Beverly you can find the baton Academy
at the service station and attempt
command building it's a different lock
mark six if you can disable the
automatic security systems monitoring
the exits you'll be able to make its
mark six I believe that we're at the God
that there's a control module with
composure security systems find a way in
locate control module
the sensor systems come back to me
you're gonna captain my hair's perfect
okay what are you gonna bail ax man I
dreamed I was a big guy like you I would
do something about the god they call the
knife inside the gods barracks like to
drive prisoners in their gorgeous them
seen the smoke rising from the chimneys
afterwards okay object
I live in here I don't think that I
really love hello my fellow comrades I
love it oh look at this side as you pay
exactly okay I'm here to fix the
plumbing
hello I'm trying to get this come on the
[ __ ] okay if we're go over there they'll
ever sees any [ __ ] else upgrades is
in there by [ __ ] people on there right
okay that's that night all right once
again in the chair you guys for voting
green fun big you know you can see only
out out there that the [ __ ] Eric
nothing one month less to do name
shaking when it's that quickly
Leslie needs up what's the [ __ ] our
okay sorry okay now look I'm over
generally held like a champ
[ __ ] where they stared why do you take
their eyes out of my way [ __ ] I'll get
[ __ ] hot in here
get the [ __ ] out of here
yes that connect you out
and I guess I fell and I how it works in
this play [ __ ]
well it's their way yeah that's what I'm
talking about the map right there we go
expand 9 Berliner is a high side but
[Music]
that's where I was I think first and
that chant will make it always watching
him the true horrors of about terrorism
we're not the ham and the guts and where
the cherubs and I went up tank ok this
is the place like ok
okay expand and soldiers are not armored
bottom system filters oh goodness okay
out of my way back
I'm on
I can't say my left acted my ass I'm
just how that kills them
at melody
okay crouch a my crowd faces on this way
chef second-place I'll turn around sir
all right yeah Calabasas [ __ ] hello
sorry okay yeah hang on
I'm lucky I'm not can woo cocktail a new
Buckethead
thank you security system disabled need
a five-set should I hide this I think I
should [ __ ] hide this now sir
so let you know I did what you asked of
me he did the right thing didn't you I'm
just hard to know what is right what you
did was a good thing
mm-hmm mystical dagger do is it what is
it do what is shut
see in here again great where that [ __ ]
hey gal that's how you go yeah he's
right back
skipped in the [ __ ] wall sometimes we
have to find other ways it was just
violent it's like this adjustment of the
chemicals the stabilizers the mixture
modulus al maseeh old mold developed our
security systems Wow what is your name
uvula
lasgo and slush of it just less coverage
so now the areas Glasgow where two men
one's a vet you can go past this gate
back through the factory out the blue
gate inside block six where the command
control building is located snake in
sight get the detour Nick Beverly please
tell gently before anyone notices what
you have done that's a high angle F
that's what luck
and I get to be quieter
all right make a snake ni hi I'm one
snake a snake can't a man build a cabin
six hey anyone in here [ __ ] see anyone
I get a [ __ ] laughing now okay will
this [ __ ] over here so I hear
[ __ ] [ __ ] are you're laughing
[ __ ] booby it was gonna flower but
even though he's [ __ ] gay she never
was gay I guess he can't come out a guy
cuz I'll [ __ ] kill him yeah so bad for
baby kinda sucks to be boba really is a
true victim of the story that's rankled
that or he has to be in here somewhere
[ __ ] they're the guys [ __ ] notice
okay man we are [ __ ] snaky these days
okay okay shut another knife this is
great I'll leave this outfit thank you
smell her at FRA angle
nothing in here I could [ __ ] a cake the
[ __ ] was that
look I just take oh what the [ __ ] was
that that was not what I want to do that
was the opposite [ __ ] who the [ __ ]
shot down the [ __ ] window will need
my sex Christ [ __ ] look at my [ __ ]
legs a rocket from Java out the window
[ __ ] [ __ ] I hate want to end up like
that [ __ ] I lost a knife to that witch
over here bucks each on [ __ ]
socket [ __ ] Gracie okay she was free to
walk right now
hey potatoes in here I could eat just
talked to says the door stop what is
that
I know where doors up to Maine I wonder
not too far dfl what's out there
[ __ ] [ __ ] violent dog food
what is night sheet though where is it
by one knife okay am I missing something
here that's stupid [ __ ]
I'll get you dance awesome
so proud of yourself next year I'll pull
it now got Matt likey
okay here we go meh [ __ ]
fuckin'-a
I'm the knife throwing ax men this will
be armor oh [ __ ] right deck
I don't know smart I am I don't think
that smart
I double dua here's an attendee phonetic
john vedoe alright
so propaganda video funnyman and in that
population are disorders
which we think ah okay was that at the
end of that mission
no chappie right very hard bro gonna get
it
why can't I stop gesturing [ __ ] me going
do their thing
we should have a sponsor
I was hot to get out yes my bad yeah
Roger comfort hey Dad holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
throw like a rag doll HSC Sigma you got
a problem
now we have understand we'd been to the
temple open the garage door
stealing vehicle and connected the gate
let's go
chaingun [ __ ] I'll be happy
so we just guess works just have
unlimited here we go okay
now but I'm really not good at this
I kind of got a lot of [ __ ] help it's
all I got
I can't tell what the [ __ ] is going on
I guess [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
well I'm not doing well in here
I wish I was better at this I really do
but I'm just just not
like [ __ ] Mecca salt
Marisa I hate that
all right guess that's not the gate
there I packed enough
here that stuff has a [ __ ] if it's
online
alright alright I get a little hang of
it I'm getting a little hang of it okay
that are weak and I know
[Music]
if any escape dr. mackee
okay sir what I'm opening the gates with
the bulk of it here this one is the
document where we're the [ __ ] Gnostic
okay looking oh yeah
this way
okay they don't want me to go that way
what's up boss
[ __ ] and eggs can't [ __ ] break down
here
it's this bet
okay the [ __ ] is still shooting like
this [ __ ] can I go through here yet
yeah well let me go through here
I'm leather I guess makes bucket stuck
in you that's right
Oh like shut I am NOT doing well now
that it okay it's get the [ __ ] out of
here alright London here wait there [ __ ]
here
[ __ ] [ __ ] here
and here we go that's our mission what
the [ __ ] is that holy yeah Labonte
to make countless but I might have
underestimated the useless 8.20 solution
epidemic
tell me now see hood is an ancient
mystical Society for millennia we have a
belated without most seekers right now
what do you do you afraid no no mama we
don't pray we invent things
mother the technology developed the
diseases essentially the head of
anything you've ever seen or imagined
and highly dangerous in the wrong hands
okay Nazis found our safety
they stole our secrets they used them to
win the world everything they have
accomplished everything was built upon
our knowledge BOTS
it wasn't the only say schema we have
hundreds of them hidden in the secret
places of the world how some small and
tentative like the ones the Nazis found
others great halls of knowledge stacked
high magnificent adventures together a
whirling like magic I can open some
gifts for such a place getting there
will be a challenge but elliptic the
safety is hidden deeper will be
affronted gray we will need a u-bolt
capable of great depth that's all
spewing a goddamn Nazi you bored this is
what you're proposing are you up your
head man the [ __ ] is that I know how to
get a u-boat but for my plant after our
veteran operation can you do it
I'm a bass you could engineer I can do
this for my flu B but need some
additional features on it too I prepare
specification for you
last Kovich helping out yes boss go in
for that guy
hmm okay so that's it for that mission
thanks for watching